the jurgen experience when you see a
story
like the jeffrey epstein story yeah
which is uh playing out right now
right boy you should talk to my son
that is one of the craziest [ __ ]
stories of our time because it's a
conspiracy theorist wet dream
no no one would have ever believed
there's an island where a guy
brings prominent scientists celebrities
and politicians to [ __ ]
underage girls they film them all and
use it to somehow or another blackmail
them or
did they film they filmed them
apparently according to galen maxwell
there's tapes
you know um i mean there's so much to
this story though so she knows something
oh for sure
so that's going to be the next uh the
next mystery
well the next mystery is how they're
going to kill her
that's the next mystery i mean how long
is it going to last
yeah i mean there's supposed to the
whole trial doesn't take place for a
year
that's a lot of time and that tombs you
feel there was a murder
from outside for upstate went yes
100 yeah the guys on suicide watch the
the film doesn't work the the
surveillance cameras don't work
and uh michael baden the uh forensic
scientist
reviews the autopsy and he's like this
man was strangled
look at the the break in the bone of the
neck that's consistent with
strangulation
look at the the position in which uh he
was choked
like which which part of the neck that's
not consistent with hanging
oh there's all the factors point to the
fact that the guy was killed
and then the fact that i mean the guys
on suicide watch
and you know how how how is it possible
that this guy was one of the most
important
witnesses in a case against
a gigantic number of very powerful
people
just winds up committing suicide whoops
no worries
sorry well if i i'm
staying away from that directly it's
such a mess it's a mess
it's a mass but that's one that i would
think would
intrigue you i mean if at the end of all
this when the pieces all fall into place
is that something you would think about
covering for a film
well if i had to write it i had to get
very interested in the subject matter it
seems
uh it doesn't uh you know
i mean it's i don't know what it's about
i mean if if it's really what they say
and there's
all these world leaders and blah blah
blah i mean it just doesn't really lead
anywhere it doesn't make sense
i mean the world is a much more
important places
world a sense of world peace and this is
the most important issue
peace in our time and we are building up
nuclear weapons
at an incredible rate under this guide
trump
and it's a huge it's a return to the
worst of the cold war and
that scares me that's an issue i would
like to
i think if i were to get involved again
in another movie if not a documentary
would be that one
about the accumulation of arms yeah the
building billboards
and the and the the madness of of our
leaders democrat and republican
constantly pushing for
more sanctions more pressure on
our perceived enemies china russia
north korea iraq iran
and it and venezuela i mean it's just
why why are we doing this we don't have
to
the world could be a much more peaceful
place if we
take our foot off the pedal
you